et voici la voiture qu'on a plus besoin
de se donner le mal de conduire pour la
raison très simple qu elle se conduit
toute seule
et oui c'est bien ce que vous croyez une
voiture autonome en 1961 encore un
miracle du radar aujourd'hui
investisseur industriel et ingénieurs
sont en pleine course dans ce marché des
voitures autonomes les avant d'être un
enjeu économique
la voiture sans chauffeur était le
fantasme des géo trouvetou comme en 1969
avec un certain monsieur smith
il est américain dans le hasard ça
arrive quitte sa villa au volant de sa
voiture électrique
ils l'engagent sur un embranchement de
la route à guidage automatique qui le
conduit jusqu'à la cause principale la
route ressemble un circuit électrique
pour enfants mais l'idée est là heureux
monsieur smith qui n'a à penser à rien
d'ailleurs il à la télé en 1971
l'électronique se perfectionne la
voiture n'a plus besoin de chauffeurs et
le journaliste s'emballe un tout petit
peu peut être verrons nous les fils en
2000 des autoroutes entièrement équipée
avec le petit faible et déjà les
avantages de la voiture autonome sont
énumérés fini le permis de conduire il
n'ya plus tôt fleurs fini le code de la
route finit même l'alcootest dans les
années 80 les constructeurs automobiles
s'intéressent de plus en plus
sérieusement à cette voiture sans
chauffeur radar câbles enterrés
nouvelles technologies et surtout
satellite
bref la voiture autonome prend forme
verra-t-on demain sur nos routes des
voitures radioguidés comme celle ci
dessus
[Musique]